when you first came out to l.a you were
very young
yeah i was 15 and a half and i say that
because it's you know specific because
you get your learner's permit at that
age right yeah and and you came out here
and you did you go all california right
away i did not i came out here at a
young age just out of college but i was
very much like a boston guy who was
stranded in l.a were you did you sort of
go well i was kind of yeah pacific
northwest in l.a but i tried to kind of
fit in
somewhat and learn the like la
stuff and you know a lot of people here
meditate and things like that and
there's this um there's this thing
called tm which is have you heard about
it trends and dental meditation which is
by the way apparently incredible i would
never know because when i went in to
learn
i walked in and you know mind you at
this point i'm probably 16 and i'm i
walk in and
you know it's like it's quiet and i've
been warned of you know cults and stuff
down in california you know and show biz
and all this stuff and going from my
small town and i'm i walk in and the
woman says
this way
and i'm like
okay we go in this room it's quiet you
know shuts the curtains i'm like oh i've
been warned about
curtain shedding i'm like what's going
on
she lights some incense and she goes
i'm going to meditate on your mantra
and i'm like what's a mantra
no idea what's happening she sits down
after what seems like a really long time
and a lot of instance burning later
she turns to me and she goes
i have your mantra
you say
what was that that's what i said
i didn't know what it was but i was not
waving this is what you're supposed to
repeat over and over and over again like
the word you're supposed to use the rest
of your life the word you're supposed to
use for the rest of your life in
transcendental meditation it's the whole
point you say this word the entire time
it's like slows your brain down and i
didn't hear what she said but i was too
young to say what
i didn't i don't understand what you're
saying because i thought if i didn't
then i wasn't hip enough to be a tm
person wait right so this person you
went and you saw this person for a long
time they meditated they gave you the
true word that well then it's weird it's
different for everyone yeah but this is
what
the word is different for everybody and
you're not supposed to tell people what
it is but this is what i heard
ike
hi
so just
stay with me i would go and try it and
this was my my meditation experience
okay
and i was like this is not calming me at
all
no that is cl that is not your isn't it
usually like uh
it's that kind of a sound that you're
you're not supposed to say your mantra
do i look like someone who has a mantra
do i look like someone who's achieved
inner peace
no this show is one 25 year long cry for
help
well i'm going to give you a mantra give
me one give me one yeah okay
here it is
i didn't hear it
what if they didn't say they're yeah
what if they just sneezed you shut the
dress
so i still did this they don't know yeah
i never went back and said hey can you
tell me again right right things have
worked out very well for you i would say
don't find out whatever you're doing
keep doing it